what's the deal with airplane peanuts
peanuts throughout the history of stand
up comedians beefing with one another
has been a constant but never before has
a behind the scenes rivalry between
managers and agents involving years of
Lies deceit and manipulation Spilled Out
into the public eye until now that is
this video contains new information that
just recently came to light information
so bizarre and out of line that it's
caused Bert Kreischer to lose sleep with
rage ever since finding out Matt Blake
and Nick nucifero are both agents who
work for two separate companies
representing comedians Matt Blake works
with Bobby Lee Andrew Schultz Tim Dillon
and Shane Gillis while Nick and chiefro
represents the likes of Bert Kreischer
Andrew Santino Sebastian and Whitney
Cummings the main purpose of their jobs
is to organize upcoming schedules book
tour dates and negotiate contracts for
the comedians that they represent it
goes without saying they work for The
Comedians and they should always have
their best interest in mind not the
other way around this is why it was so
shocking last week when Bert found out
live on tigerbelly the real reason it's
been so difficult to work with many of
his comedic peers represented by Matt
Blake stems from an ongoing beef that
started 15 years ago between Burke's
agent Nick and Matt Blake now most
people would assume something real
serious must have happened for these two
adults each representing high-profile
entertainers to have carried out an
argument for 15 years and let it affect
their everyday business decisions right
wrong turns out it was all over a
thermostat in fact I I so there's a
photo in my phone no it's
oh right so they used to work together
at an agency and they hated each other
because of the temperature of the room
they fought over the temperature right
so would like it hot how am I just
hearing about this it's an original
story yeah this is real thermostat beef
because I will tell you thermostat brief
thermostat
it's about the temperature of the office
what are you [__] no this is no this
is real so because of this thermostat
beef Bobby Lee was blocked from joining
the fully loaded Cruise the fully loaded
festival and doing some normal weekends
alongside Bert on the road even though
Bert made it clear that Bobby was his
number one choice Bobby was my first
go-to he was my first go-to for that
what'd you do and he and immediately he
said no no listen I'll tell you how
someone says no Tim Dillon shout out to
Tim Dylan yeah he said yes we signed it
on and then he goes I can't do it but he
called me and said hey man I'm not gonna
be able to do it and you're like okay I
got it that's nice it goes even deeper
than just Burton Bobby though because
these same agents also made sure Andrew
Schultz and Tim Dylan were not involved
in any Bert Chrysler events whatsoever
I'm talking about like Biden and a trump
kind of animosity name three other
really big Comics at that company
Shane Gillis but he's in I saw him no no
no yeah Andrew Schultz Tim Dylan Tim
Dylan
Tim Dylan shout out to Tim Dillon yeah
he said yes we signed it on and then he
goes I can't do it this is all over the
[__] thermostat
even beside the fact that we're talking
about two of the biggest names in comedy
that would instantly add value to any
festival lineup Tim Dylan Andrew Schultz
and Bobby Lee are all legitimate friends
of Bert who prior to him learning this
information thought these guys were just
ghosting and avoiding him for no reason
Bobby Lee's agent denying him of
multiple huge opportunities to perform
in arenas and baseball stadiums just to
satisfy his own personal grudge against
Bert's agent is absurd in its own right
but the fact that he's willing to speak
on Bobby's behalf literally putting
words in his mouth regarding what shows
he will or will not do with his own
friends without even showing Bobby those
offers first that blows my mind
especially when you see just how eager
Bobby was to actually be a part of all
these events they're like you know you
just got Sober Do you want to be on a uh
yacht Cruise yeah for 30 days or
whatever and I got maybe 30 days it's
not 30
we're not going to South America it's
just to the [__] Islands out of Miami
it's three days three days three days
that's all it is it's not 30 [__]
days three days
oh man most drama between comedians
doesn't really affect much outside of
those specific relationships but when it
comes to this situation comedy fans have
a right to be pissed the amount of
Comedy content we have now all missed
out on because of these two dumb agents
goes way deeper than just fully loaded
the bad Friends tour was heavily delayed
and almost canceled because Santino has
the same agent as Bert Bobby Lee was
supposed to join Bert on his regular
tour last year in arenas but the deal
was mysteriously denied it's honestly
shocking they could even get Shane
Gilles to do fully loaded now that we
know this it'll be interesting to see
The Fallout from this information not
only being exposed to The Comedians but
also to the masses of Comedy fans online
Bert's reaction to hearing all of this
on tigerbelly was pretty jarring you
could tell that he was actually
devastated hopefully these Asians can be
held accountable in some way for putting
their own interests ahead of their own
clients these guys come off as total
morons losing thousands of dollars in
contracts and driving wedges in
established relationships because of a
thermostat there is still a lot of
positivity to take away from this
information being leaked just like Bert
and Bob discussed to end the episode
comedians have continued to become more
and more independent and detached from
the normal system it seems like they've
begun to realize they don't need these
agents nearly as much as these agents
need them and they especially don't need
any agents that are grown men fighting
over the thermostat setting from 2008.
Guess spots from last week The Joe Rogan
Experience had on Duncan Trussell and
Gabriel Iglesias your mom's house talked
with Lauren Compton Bobby Lee was the
guest on being Ian with Jordan kill Tony
this week was with Theo Von two bears
one cave was bertinari Giannis Papas and
Paul verzi were both on we might be
drunk gustavi's World talked with Joe
list Chrissy chaos had on Sam Talent
Andrew Santino was on hey babe and Chris
DiStefano was a guest on flagrant and I
just snapped when she asked me about a
chore that I didn't do about throwing
out the garbage and we just got into it
and the kids were right there and then I
I just had to walk away and I took a
shower and I told Akash I was screaming
into the towels in the attic
to just trying to get upstairs as far as
he could go
my children were in the basement they
were doing like an activity down there
that's where their playroom is and I
went up to the top layer and I screamed
as loud as I can into the annex and just
yelled obscenities out myself took a
shower came back downstairs and I said
you know what I already met I messed
something up I did not control my
reactions in the right way but what I
all I can do now is show the children
that if you make a mistake if you make a
mistake all you can do is try to be
better for it this is going to tie into
Juneteenth
this past weekend with Thea Von talked
with drunken Trussell Matt and Shane's
secret podcast head on Lil sass Rich
Voss was on Dr Drew after dark are you
garbage head on Ali siddiq taste buds
battled stub toe vs paper cut Rachel
Wolfson was on the Honeydew Gator from
Dave was the guest on Whiskey Ginger
Josh Homme was on the blocks podcast and
Bert Kreischer was on tigerbelly as far
as new stand-up specials that are either
out right now or coming out soon the
most excited I've been for a Netflix
special in a long time Tom Segura
Sledgehammer is coming out next week on
the 4th of July this will be Tom's fifth
special that he's made for Netflix
cementing him as an original stand-up
comedy staple on one of the biggest
streamers in the world we also have some
new specials out on YouTube for you Mark
Norman presents Matt Ruby's substance a
full hour for Matt Ruby out right now on
Mark Norman's YouTube channel we also
had a surprise Banger for Matt Rife
dropping a full-length crowd work
special just a few months after
uploading his previous full hour and
Jake's now special boy came out on
YouTube last week we also have the fully
loaded tour continuing to roll on
honestly the most electric event
anywhere in stand-up comedy right now
the content coming out of this Festival
so far has been nuts it's mind-blowing
to think that somehow fully loaded could
have been even better than it actually
is right now if these agents didn't act
like children it really seems like
everyone in comedy is on the road right
now this summer has been packed with
extensive tours for majority of the top
comics in the game I just saw the
Yvonne's latest hour in person last
weekend and it was incredible the show
exceeded my expectations by so much that
I decided it needs a full recap video so
they'll be coming out soon on this
channel if you don't want to miss it be
sure to subscribe right now thank you so
much for watching
at joke world
and the world is wrld
[Music]
thank you